ces deux mêmes messieurs en outaouais en
fait à gatineau plus précisément que
débute le 87e congrès de l'association
francophone pour le savoir la phase
radio canada vous savez en parle
toujours amplement on accorde une belle
place à la science profite de l'occasion
également et met en lumière donc sur
toutes ses plateformes les sciences
pendant cette semaine des sciences mon
invité pour en parler bien vous allez
reconnaître rapidement charles tisseyre
de l'émission découverte plongeon cher
aujourd'hui j'ai d'abord parlons de
l'importance de ce congrès la la phase
c'est majeur pour la science ou six
majeur parce que ça se passe en français
et l'on sait que la langue
internationale de la science quand on
publie quand on va à des conférences
internationales si ces marais souvent
l'ordinaire
alors voici un très grand événement qui
rejoint des centaines de chercheurs qui
les regroupe en un endroit à gatineau
université du québec en outaouais et
pendant toute la semaine ils vont
discuter de sciences dans presque tous
les domaines de la science alors
plusieurs colloques plusieurs
présentations qui pendant toute cette
semaine qu'ils abordent tout plein de
sujets qui nous touchent
particulièrement certains l ont entre
autres les changements climatiques les
inondations exactement il est le
quatorzième colloque justement là-dessus
on sait que bon il ya eu des vagues de
chaleur terrible l'été dernier avec
presque 70 morts les inondations ils
vont parler de ça en détail
l'adaptation au changement climatique et
qu'il faut s'adapter la planète on ne
reviendra plus à la planète qu'on a
connus mais on peut de roulement
améliorer les choses en s'adaptant le
développement durable intelligence
artificielle l'activité physique pour le
la santé mentale et la santé physique et
j'en passe c'est inné c'est vraiment une
liste formidable c'est une grande
moisson cette année deux sujets vraiment
vraiment captivant et puis ma radio
canada avec la wii on va être là et on
va décliner
multitude de sujets sont différentes
plateformes oui absolument
on va être sur le web on va et au
téléjournal on va être à la première
chaîne avec à la radio alors catherine
mercier de la semaine verte est une des
ambassadrices et puis bien sûr se fiant
dry blondin des années lumière france
beaudoin de la semaine verte et moi-même
de découverte et au téléjournal par
exemple catherine mercier va présenter
une interview sur la valeur des armes
l'importance des arbres en milieu urbain
qui filtre l'air qui vont qui vont
réduire le risque de ruissellement de
l'eau etc qui vont réduire la chaleur
des îlots de chaleur qui sont tellement
problématique en milieu urbain france
beaudoin va nous parler de la santé du
saint laurent qui est attaqué par les
bactéries qui sont déversés dans les
eaux usées par les antibiotiques qui se
retrouvent dans le fleuve par les
pesticides également qui viennent des
terres agricoles
c'est un grand reportage qui va diffuser
cet automne mais au téléjournal france à
nous présenter 100 en 4 minutes et a
découverte nous on va parler du ciseau
moléculaire qui découpe l'adn qui a été
entre autres carrés six ans petit ciseau
qui existe naturellement dans les
bactéries
c'est le chercheur sylvain moineau de
l'université laval à québec qui a
caractérisé avec des collègues d'autres
équipes comment fonctionne ce ciseau là
d'autres équipes ensuite on a pris à
l'exploiter le manipulé de telle sorte
qu éventuellement peut-être on pourrait
guérir certaines maladies héréditaires
d'origine génétique grâce à ce ciseau
moléculaire alors ça ça va être la
semaine prochaine au téléjournal se
fiant dray va avoir une émission
spéciale aux années lumière qui va être
enregistrée jeudi et qui sera diffusé
dimanche aux années aux ailes lui mais
on parle en coulisses d'une balade on
s'appelle par asus
c'est intéressant parce qu'en fait ce
sont des découvertes scientifiques qui
n'étaient pas prévus en fait on fait
souvent en sciences ont fait des
découvertes sans avoir cherché la cible
qu'on qu'on trouve la pénicilline c'est
un bon exemple on a découvert que dans
un plat de pétri
des bactéries qui semblent disparaître
est attaqué par quelque chose on s'est
rendu compte que c'était un petit
champignon microscopique donné naissance
à la pénicilline m'ont cherché passe à
un autre exemple c'est le viagra le
viagra c'était pour traiter les maladies
cardiaques
l'insuffisance cardiaque s'est dit
vasodilatateur sauf que les patients qui
ont commencé à dire à leur médecin
écouter juge ça va vraiment mieux ma vie
en ce moment et on s'est rendu compte
qu'ils avaient donc le cette possibilité
d'améliorer la fonction sexuelle et ça
s'est fait par hasard
donc cette balade aux traits de ce genre
de sujets là avec justement elle canal
vie qui est l'animatrice et ça se fait
de façon très naturelle très vivant très
sympathique très intéressant
interminable parlez nous de la preuve la
preuve par l'image
oui ça c'est un concours organisé par la
crasse qui est absolument formidable et
scientifiques quand ils font des
recherches sont rendus compte qu'en
prenant des photos de leurs recherches
parfois le résultat était très
esthétique très beau sur le plan
artistique avant alors c'est un contenu
on en voit à l'écran actuellement ça
c'est là c'est la cuvée la moisson si je
puis dire de 2019 l'édition 2010 9 20
images ont été sélectionnés et de cela
plusieurs gagneront des prix du jury et
il y aura aussi le prix coup de coeur de
découverte de radio canada qui sera
remis au gagnant et donc on invite le
public à voter pour son image
kruger jusqu'au 15 septembre et tout
cela va être exposé à espace pour la vie
au planétarium et les gens vont pouvoir
aller voir sur place et sur le site de
radio canada
aussi bien chez extrêmement intéressant
sharks a comme à chacune de vos visites
à la planche est tellement vraiment dans
la semaine des sciences à radio-canada
et avec la face c'est passionnant oui je
me gênerait pas occupez-vous cette
semaine c'est oui merci beaucoup chartis
merci à vous